>> Greg: NEW VIDEO SHOWS THE
BORDER IS ANYTHING BUT UNDER
CONTROL.
FOX NEWS CAMERAS HANDLING
EXCLUSIVE FOOTAGE AGAIN.
DOZENS OF MIGRANTS CROSSING THE
RIO GRANDE RIVER IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT.
FIVE INCLUDING A BABY ABANDONED
IN THE BLISTERING HEAT.
HERE IS THE MOMENT THEY WERE
FOUND.
>> NO MOTHER, NO MOTHER, NO
FATHER, NO NOTHING.
THIS IS ONE OF OUR WORKER'S
WIVES RIGHT HERE TAKING CARE OF
THIS TINY ONE.
NO ONE WITH THESE CHILDREN.
>> Greg: SO JUAN, YOU'VE GOT
20 GOVERNORS URGING BIDEN TO ACT
ON THIS CRISIS.
THERE IS A HARVARD POLL THAT
SAYS THAT THE RESPONDENTS
OVERWHELMINGLY WANT ACTION NOW,
EVEN TO EMBRACE TRUMP'S FORMER
BORDER GOALS, BECAUSE THEY SEEM
TO BE WORKING.
CAN YOU ACTUALLY SAY THAT THESE
PEOPLE, HEY, THIS HAS HAPPENED
BEFORE.
THIS HAS BEEN AROUND FOREVER.
YOU THINK THEY ARE WANT TO BUY
THAT SHTICK?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK IT'S A
SHTICK AND I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
HAS TO BUY IT.
YOU CAN SHOW THESE VIDEOS.
DID ONE YESTERDAY.
DIDN'T WANT TODAY.
YOU KNOW, IT'S ONE VIDEO OUT OF
CONTEXT ABOUT, YOU KNOW, AS I
SAID YESTERDAY, PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DONE MIKE HAVE BEEN CROSSING THE
RIO GRANDE FOR CENTURIES IN TERS
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THE THE BROADER POINT ABOUT
WHETHER THE BORDER IS OPEN OR
THE BORDER IS CLOSED I THINK
AGAIN, JUST LOOK AT THE FACTS
BECAUSE THE FACTS ARE THAT
THE COYOTES MAY HAVE TOLD PEOPLE
OH, WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN, THEY
ARE GOING TO LET YOU IN.
BUT THE FACT IS OVER THE LAST
MONTH, WE'VE SEEN AN 88, NEARLY
90% DROP IN THE NUMBER OF
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS CROSSING
THAT BORDER.
AND WE'VE SEEN ALSO A SIMILAR
HIGH LEVEL OF DROP IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBER OF ARRESTS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS OF ANY AGE CROSSING
THE BORDER, INDICATING THAT
THERE ARE FEWER PEOPLE TRYING TO
CROSS.
SO TO MY MIND, WE HAVE TO JUST
STOP ALL THE ALARMISTS TYPE OF
ATTITUDE AND MAKING THIS VIDEO
INTO SOMETHING THAT HAS NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE AND SAY WE NEED
ACTION.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE
HEARING FROM THE GOVERNORS.
WE NEED ACTION TO DEAL WITH OUR
BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, AND
REALLY, THE PRESIDENT, FOR ALL
YOU TALK ABOUT BUILD A WALL,
THAT WOULDN'T STOP PEOPLE FROM
CROSSING THE RIO GRANDE.
WHAT WE NEED IS CONGRESS.
WHAT WE NEED IS CONGRESS TO
ORGANIZE A LEGAL IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM, A BETTER BORDER SECURITY
SYSTEM.
MAKE A DEAL WITH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
LET'S COME TOGETHER AND STOP THE
SELFIES AND THE --
>> Greg: YOU KEEP SAYING STOP
THE SELFIES.
BUT IT'S THE DEMOCRATS WHO
PIONEERED THE SELFIES.
YOU REMEMBER AOC?
YOU KEEP SAYING STOP THE
SELFIES.
YOU NEED NEW TALKING POINTS?
NUMBER ONE, I'M GLAD THAT YOU
AGREE THAT VIDEOS OUT OF CONTEXT
ARE WRONG, FINALLY.
NUMBER TWO, THE NUMBER OF
MIGRANT CHILDREN, THE NUMBER OF
MIGRANT CHILDREN HAVE DOUBLED IN
THE LAST TWO MONTHS.
JESSE, ARE THERE ANY OTHER FACTS
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADD?
>> Juan: THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN HAS DECREASED, GREG.
IT'S GONE DOWN.
OH, MY GOSH.
OKAY.
>> Jessie: LET ME ADDRESS --
TO THE MISINFORMED HERE, THE
SITUATION ON THE BORDER IS NOT
IMPROVING.
BORDER CROSSINGS ARE NOT DOWN.
WE'VE HAD TO GO STRAIGHT MONTHS
OF OVER 170,000 BORDER CROSSERS.
THOSE ARE TO GO STRAIGHT MONTHS
OF 20 YEAR HIGHS.
IN FACT, MONTH OVER MONTH,
ADULTS ARE FOUND CROSSING MORE
THAN THEY WERE BEFORE.
ALSO, JUAN SAYS THIS IS NORMAL.
IT IS NOT NORMAL FOR A PARADE OF
50 PEOPLE FROM VENEZUELA GOING
ACROSS THE RIO GRANDE RIVER IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT AND THEN JUST
TURNING THEMSELVES OVER TO A
BORDER PATROL AGENT TO GAIN THE
ASYLUM SYSTEM.
THE SECOND THING THEY LIKE TO
SAY IS, OH, WELL THEY ARE REALLY
SPEEDING UP THE PROCESS OF
GETTING THESE KIDS OUT OF
CUSTODY.
THAT WAS DEBUNKED TODAY BY THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS, WHO SAYS THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS MORE
THAN DOUBLED THE AMOUNT OF
CHILDREN IN CUSTODY OVER THE
LAST TWO MONTHS.
THEY ARE NOW KEEPING 21,000
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS IN FEDERAL
CUSTODY AND A SECRET NETWORK OF
200 DIFFERENT FACILITIES ACROSS
THE SPAN OF OVER TWO DOZEN
STATES.
THERE IS ONE IN TEXAS THAT HAS
OVER 4,000 UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
PACKED TIGHT INTO IT.
AND THE LAST THING YOU ALWAYS
HEAR ABOUT REPUBLICANS TAKING
SELFIES AND CONGRESS NEEDS TO
ACT.
REPUBLICANS ARE TAKING PICTURES
OF KIDS IN CAGES.
BIDEN WOULDN'T LET THE PRESS
INTO THE FACILITY.
THE LAST TIME I CHECKED,
REPUBLICANS DON'T CONTROL EITHER
CHAMBER.
NANCY AND CHUCK HAVE NOT MOVED
ON ANY IMMIGRATION POLICY CHANGE
AND THAT IS ON THEM.
>> Greg: JUST TO POINT OUT
FROM A RESEARCH PACKET, AND I
SPOKE TO OUR PRODUCERS ON THIS,
I WOULD NEVER TAKE THE DATA THAT
THEY GIVE US.
THIS IS CONFIDENTIAL DATA, DANA,
WHICH SHOWS THE NUMBER, YOU CAN
LAUGH, I GUESS.
LAUGHING ABOUT THE MIGRANT
CHILDREN.
IN GOVERNMENT CUSTODY, IT HAS
MORE THAN DOUBLED IN THE PAST
TWO MONTHS.
YOU CAN LAUGH AT THIS.
I GUESS IT'S FUNNY TO YOU.
BUT ANYWAY --
'S BEFORE I SET OVER THE LAST
MONTH.
IF YOU DON'T DISTORT THE
NUMBERS, I WANT HAVE TO.
>> Greg: I'M READING IT.
I'M ACTUALLY READING IT.
YOU HAD YOUR CHANCE.
ALL RIGHT, DANA.
>> Juan: YET, YOU HAD YOUR
CHANCE AND YOU DISTORT THE
NUMBERS.
>> Greg: OH, GOD HELP US.
>> Juan: I SAID IT'S DOWN 80
PLUS PERCENT IN THE LAST MONTH.
>> Greg: IF YOU CAN'T READ THE
STATS, YOU ARE CONFUSED, JUAN.
>> Juan: OH, YEAH, RIGHT.
>> Greg: I'M TRYING TO GET TO
YOU.
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME.
YOU COULD ARGUE THAT THOSE
FARMERS SAVED TO THOSE KIDS'
LIVES AND IF THAT FARMER WASN'T
THERE, WE WOULD BE HAVING A VERY
DIFFERENT DISCUSSION RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: RIGHT.
WHAT ABOUT THAT FARMER.
WHAT IF IT HAD GOTTEN TO THE
POINT WHERE THE LITTLE BABY WHO
WAS SO DEHYDRATED THAT SHOULD
DOMINIC SAID SHE WAS BARELY
MOVING.
WHAT IF SHE HADN'T SURVIVED?
>> Greg: YEAH.
THEY WANT THE FARMER AND HIS
WIFE HAPPENED UPON THIS TRAGEDY
AND THEN THEY HAD THAT ON THEIR
CONSCIENCE?
THAT'S NOT FAIR TO THEM AT ALL.
IT'S TERRIBLE FOR THESE GIRLS.
THIS IS THE INHUMANITY OF ALL OF
THE SPEAR I HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION.
WHEN YOU SHOW THE VIDEO, IT'S
ACTUALLY NEWS FOOTAGE.
OTHER NETWORKS, THEY ARE FREE TO
GOING TO COVER IT TOO.
OUR CAMERAS WERE JUST THERE.
THEY JUST HAPPENED TO BE THERE.
LIKE OKAY, WE ARE TO SHOWING YOU
WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE.
YOU CAN DECIDE WITH YOUR OWN
EYES WHAT YOU ARE SEEING.
BUT THERE IS A VIDEO.
THERE IS A GUY IN THERE.
JESSE POINTED HIM OUT YESTERDAY.
HE WAS THE COYOTE WITH THE MASK
AROUND HIS FACE.
>> Greg: YET.
>> Dana: WE SAW HIM YESTERDAY.
AND WE SAW HIM TODAY.
AND HE IS BRINGING THE VIOLENT
DOLL MY VENEZUELANS ACROSS AND
HE GETS PAID.
HE DOESN'T CARE WHAT HAPPENS TO
THEM AFTER THAT.
WHY IS IT THAT GUY GETTING
ARRESTED QUESTION MUST BE TO
WRITE.
>> Dana: WHY ARE WE TAKING HIM
OUT?
>> Katie: GOOD QUESTION.
>> Dana: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT HERE WE'VE GOT EYES ON HIM.
HE'S RIGHT THERE.
>> Greg: KATIE, TO DANA'S
POINT, IT'S AMAZING HOW TRAGEDY
IS COVERED.
JOURNALISM SUDDENLY BECOMES AN
ACT OF SMOTHERING.
THEY PUT UP A STORY OR THEY
DON'T EVEN LOOK AT IT.
>> Katie: YEAH, AND TODAY'S
POINT, I HAVE A FRIEND WHO HAS A
RANCH DOWN ON THE BORDER OF
TEXAS AND SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WORKING ON OTHER RANCHES.
YESTERDAY HE TEXTED ME AND SAID
RANCHERS ARE STARTING TO FIND
BODIES MORE OFTEN BUT THEY WON'T
EVER SHOW THAT BECAUSE GETTING
HOT AND THEY AREN'T PREPARED TO
DEAL WITH THE SITUATION.
SO IT IS NOT NORMAL FOR PEOPLE
TO BE DYING ON PRIVATE PROPERTY
AND RANCHES IN TEXAS.
IT'S NOT NORMAL FOR DROP OFF
LITTLE BABIES THAT CAN'T EVEN
WALK YET ON RANCHES AND ABANDON
THEM.
IT'S NOT NORMAL.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT HUMANE AS
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
REPEATEDLY ARGUED.
THEY'VE SET OVER AND OVER AGAIN,
OUR POLICIES ARE MORE HUMANE
THAN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
'OF POLICIES.
WELL GUESS WHAT?
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF HUMANE.
OPEN BORDERS ARE INHUMANE
BORDERS.
WE KNOW THIS.
AND TO SAY THAT IT IS BEING
BLOWN OUT OF PROPORTION ARE THAT
IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME IS
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THIS A
ADMINISTRATION TOLD US THEY WERE
GOING TO DO AND IT'S NOT RIGHT.
IT'S WRONG.
>> Greg: WE HAVE TO REMIND
OURSELVES THAT THE WALL IS